ووصف المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
تصريحات وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي باسرائيل
الداعيه لمحو قريه حوار الفلسطينيه بغير
المسؤوله والمثيره للاشمئزاز على حد قوله
ادعى الاسرائيلي
مشيرا الى انها تحرض على العنف
اريد ان اكون واضحا بشكل لا لبس فيه هذه
التصريحات غير مسؤوله وبغيظه ومثيره
للاشتزاز وكما ندين التحريض الفلسطيني على
العنف فاننا نعرب عن ادانتنا لهذه
التصريحات الاستفزازيه التي ترقى ايضا الى
التحريض على العنف ندعو رئيس الوزراء يمين
نتنياهو وغيره من كبار المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين الى رفض هذه التعليقات
والتنصل منها علنا وبوضوح اننا ندين
الارهاب والتطرف بالجميع اشكاله باستمرار
وما زلنا نحث على وجود تدابير متساويه
للمسائله عن الاعمال المتطرفه بغض النظر
عن خلفيه الجناه او الضحايا اعربنا عن
قلقنا حيال العنف العشوائي الواسع النطاق
من قبل المستوطنين ضد المدنيين
الفلسطينيين في حواره
من الخارجيه الامريكيه مراسله الجزيره
احمد هزيم احمد اهلا بك اذا تحت اي عنوان
ياتي هذا الموقف الامريكي وهذه اللهجه
ايضا في التصريحات برايس حيالهم يدور في
تل ابيب تحديدا تصريحات وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي
سفيان هذه اللهجه الحاده والغير
الاعتياديه وربما غير المسبوقه في انتقاد
تصريحات لمسؤوله اسرائيلي من قبل الولايات
المتحده وهنا المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الامريكيه هي
علامه واشاره على درجه الامتعاض الامريكي
من تصرفات وتصريحات السياسيين
الاسرائيليين خصوصا اولئك في لاقصى اليمين
المتحالفين مع رئيس الوزراء ويشكلون
الائتلاف الحاكم حاليا هناك في في اسرائيل
هذا الامتعاض الاميركي استمعنا جزءا منه
كان كان حادا عندما انتقد ما وصفه بجرائم
المستوطنين
الاسرائيليين في الضفه الغربيه واعتبر ان
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لا تقوم بالتصدي
او لا تحاول ان تمنع هذه الجرائم ارتفع
هذا الامتعاط درجه اخرى اليوم بعد تصريحات
وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي الذي اعتبرها كما
استمعنا له بانها مقززه ومثيره للاشمئزاز
وتدعو الى العنف وهي جاءت كما قال في
اعقاب اتفاق العقبه الذي ان كان بحد ذاته
مهم وهذا القول لند برايس انما هو تطبيقه
هو الاهم
لتحقيق غايته وروحه وهو خفض التسعين وان
هذه التصرفات الاسرائيليه عمليات الاقتحام
المستمره عمليات هدم المنازل المستمره
التصريحات التي ادلى بها وزير الماليه لا
تصب في هذا الاتجاه وانما على الطرفين حسب
ما قال
اتخاذ اجراءات في الاتجاه المعاكسه في
اتجاه التهدئه خفض التصعيد الابتعاد
الامريكي ايضا له انعكاس منذ مقتل او
اغتيال الزميله شيرين سفيان عندما دفعت
الولايات المتحده على بالجانب الاسرائيلي
الى تغيير قواعد الاشتباك لتجنب سقوط
مدنيين منذ ذلك الحين وسقوط المدنيين
الفلسطينيين في عمليات اقتحام قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيليه متزايد تحدث اليوم
بان كم يه الدم التي اهدرت في هذه
الاقتحامات وهدرت في هذا التصعيد في الضفه
الغربيه كبيره للغايه ويجب ان تتوقف سفيان
احمد هزيم شكرا لك